all right this is different well it's
kind of different not totally different
so I noticed there are no movies coming
out this week that I truly give a [__]
about but Final Fantasy 7 rebirth has a
demo that's out played that care about
that if only I had a YouTube channel
which I could talk about that way I do
so all right we're going to talk about
that this isn't a review it's just kind
of what I call word vomit just my
thoughts also as I talk about this I
will talk about what was shown on screen
but I'm not going to talk about oh where
it's going to go later I'm going to
approach this like you have never played
Final Fantasy 7 before so no spoilers
except for you know what's in the demo
currently like it it ends off at a point
I'm not going to tell you what happens
after that I will not rob you of
experiencing the story of neheim that
would be messed up so the Final Fantasy
7 rebirth demo starts out in calm and
Cloud's like hey let me tell you a story
about neheim I didn't actually think the
demo was going to do this it being so
lore heavy and important I thought they
were going to save that for the game but
it is the next step after uh midgar
after midgar you go to call home and
Cloud's like so here's how it went down
and actually after you finish the demo
it tells you okay in the game you don't
have to play the neheim segment you can
skip it to which I say I never skip
neheim I will play it again because I've
played it through Crisis Core multiple
times through Final Fantasy 7 proper
multiple times neheim has got to be my
favorite Town storyline in any Final
Fantasy ever I actually propos the
hypothesis that the story of neheim as
it starts to how concludes all of it is
what elevates Final Fantasy 7 to be the
god tier status it currently is it truly
mind [__] my mind so it's cool to see
that in this remake cinematic structure
so in this demo it goes down like Final
Fantasy 7 does you know you stroll up to
neheim you got Sethro in your party he's
this cool dude that you could definitely
have a drink with kind of seems like a
guy who wouldn't have a drink he's that
to the job but still he has that stature
and presence of a leader you want him to
respect you just kind of the point all
around good dude right nothing can go
wrong any yeah as it's Cloud telling the
story you go into tifa's house and she
interrupts like you went into my house
and you can be like yes or no yep I I
went through your drawers but yeah you
can play the piano I don't think I have
a capture of me playing the piano guess
I didn't want the internet knowing I
suck at playing a digital piano on a PS5
controller point is I was
[Music]
like and then I left basically how I
actually do play a piano so there is
that then you got to hike to this
reactor that's when the battles happen
it gives you a fair amount of material
to play with but getting into the
battles man I had to Slough off that
rust I felt like Tom Cruz and top gun
Maverick when he sits in his old fighter
jet cockpit and he's like it's been a
minute a Sethro in this game plays
exactly how he plays on the PlayStation
or PS1 if you prefer he's absolutely
completely broken and it's amazingly
satisfying dispatching enemies with him
there's even some Uncharted climbing
mechanics integrated into here I will
say the boss in the Final Fantasy 7
rebirth demo the boss of this segment is
not as difficult as the Scorpion
Sentinel who was the boss in the Final
Fantasy 7 remake demo he just wasn't the
Scorpion Sentinel you had to use Barrett
in some scenarios cloud and others this
one's like all right player you want to
beat the [__] out of them or beat the
[__] out of him how you want to do it
Shinra Manor layout's different I found
that weird that threw me off I was like
it's not there it's over there and tone
of voice being everything when Cloud
goes back and visits Sethro after about
a week and he's read all these books he
is just different always was the case
but again that's the great part of
playing the story in this playable
cinematic Glory you see the moment he
sounds different his tone of voice has
changed this is not the same guy you
went into battle with a week ago he is
he's just built different now and it
does hit a little different when I play
this game I will try not to nitpick you
know it's like oh that's not exactly how
it went down in the old game Shinra
Manor layout's different I found that
weird that threw me off but it's worth
addressing how things are executed makes
it hit different you know in Final
Fantasy 7 you just come up on Sethro
killing a couple people and then he
looks up at you and he has that iconic
moment you know like is that the most
iconic shot in video game history it's
like anytime a property or a something
uses Sethro it's an opportunity to show
that moment I mean [__] it's his wind
screen and Smash Brothers ultimate even
Game of Thrones season 8 was like like
yeah we'll take that thanks but you play
through it more you have this kind of
tedious but I get it moment where you're
pushing the L2 and R2 buttons and you're
trying to crawl while he's just killing
folks then he walks by you and turns
around and that's when the iconic shot
is it's almost like it's like oh oh yeah
that's right I got to turn around and do
that one shot I'll even look down and
then look up at you so I can look up at
you and perfect but as he walks into the
fire that's where the demo ends I guess
there's going to be another demo also
that plays more with the open world
element to it I guess it got me more
excited than all of the trailers I mean
there was actually this short trailer
that came out it was like the two
trailers ago not the last one not the
most recent one but the one before it
just a couple minutes long that was
actually my favorite trailer but
something about playing it and being in
the world doing the combat experiencing
this chapter of the story I do like how
this does have references bits of
dialogue visual cues that if you know
you know and if you don't you'll just be
like like all right whatever it's just
doesn't mean anything if that makes
sense like people who know the story of
Final Fantasy 7 are going to be like
that Leo DiCaprio meme people who don't
might not think anything of it point is
it just gets me excited it gets me
excited to experience the whole thing in
cinematic Glory gets me excited for
other people who haven't to experience
this for the first time yes the last
game dealt with those reccon Spirit
whisper things and we're going to deal
with them in here too I hope they don't
use those things to undo or keep from
happening very important and iconic
moments from Final Fantasy 7 that again
were other things that led to Final
Fantasy 7 hitting god tier those moments
are very important moments we've kind of
already seen how that's
possible we'll see how it plays out
point is Final Fantasy 7 rebirth demo I
thought it was great I love the fact
that it's the neheim segment to a point
anyway I mean there's more that happens
after Sethro walks away from cloud but
again that's what I like about it I like
that you get neheim but you don't get
all of it it's a proper hook you know
like if I'm just playing this and I
never played Final Fantasy 7 I'd be like
what happens next I have to play guess I
got to pre-order it oh I guess that's
the point of demos first of the Final
Fantasy 7 rebirth demo have you played
it what did you think about it whatever
you thought comment below let me know
and as always if you like what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see
more
[Music]